there's renewed guidance this morning
from the centers for disease control and
prevention about what mass to wear
against the highly infectious omicron
variant the agency now recommends
wearing quote the most protective mask
you can to help stop the spread that
includes those marked n-95 or k-n-95
those masks were initially in short
supply at the start of the pandemic the
recommendation comes as the scramble
intensifies to find covet 19 tests and
at the white house and as the white
house we should say prepares to make
millions more tests available online
next week michael george is here with
the very latest michael good morning
michelle good morning a lot of americans
still having a tough time finding
at-home testing kits well starting
wednesday the biden administration will
offer free at-home tests through a new
government website up to four per
household the high demand for tests
comes as health experts hope omicron is
near its peak
producing at home rapid tests is a
round-the-clock operation in some places
people have seen the consequences of not
knowing if they are infected or not and
i think that people are more aware of
the value of being tested regularly we
want to keep schools open we want people
to go back to work and we want them to
do it safely
but keeping schools open is a challenge
in chicago where students friday
protested the resumption of in-person
learning we need to be respected and we
need to be protected in new york schools
are making plans for the possibility of
a return to remote learning i'm going to
draw a rectangle but new orleans school
district will require students as young
as five to be vaccinated by february
first in the last week more than sixteen
hundred new students there tested
positive
nationally only 35 percent of children
aged 5 to 17 are fully vaccinated and
since last month pediatric
hospitalizations rose more than 360
percent a mix of coveted cases and other
ailments emergency rooms are full
more people are showing up all the time
we want to help hospitals handle the
volume of patients washington's governor
jay inslee called in the national guard
to help his state's hospitals from the
white house there's also support from
fema director deanne criswell i am now
directing an expansion of our fema
policy to permit funding to states who
elect to use their national guard troops
to fill these critical support roles in
hospitals the federal government is also
putting boots on the ground across the
country so now dod is deploying six
additional teams to ohio michigan rhode
island new jersey new york and new
mexico
these teams are in addition then the
more than thousand staff that are
already deployed to 26 states two
territories the district of columbia and
24 tribal nations
and after the supreme court ruled
against the administration's vaccine or
test mandate for large businesses
general electric announced they'll no
longer require employees to get
vaccinated or test regularly michelle
i'm going to let jeff take this one
thank you michael